So we're doing this series Graham - thank you
for coming back to Computerphile - about the
most important thing in computing, or one of
the most important things; have you got
something for us? Yeah, I think so. So maybe
it's not the most important, but it's certainly
one of the most interesting, and one of
the weirdest ideas in Computer
Science, and that is the Y combinator. The
background to this, is that in the last
video we did an introduction to the
Lambda Calculus, and this generated quite
a lot of discussion and comments, which
was very nice, but it turned out that the
top comment was "can we have more on the
Y combinator?" So that's what we're going
to do today. So what the Y combinator
actually is, is a way of doing recursion
in a language which doesn't have any
recursion, or any looping mechanism at
all. So what we'll start off with is a
quick refresher about what recursion
actually is. So recursion is the idea of
defining things in terms of themselves,
and a simple example of this is the
well-known factorial function, so let's
have a little look at this. The way
factorial works is you give it a number
like 3, and it's going to count down from
3 to 1, and multiply up all the numbers
in between. So for example, factorial of 3
then would be 3 times 2 times 1, which
would give us the result 6. And then we
can think how do we actually define this
function? And it turns out that the
factorial function has a very simple, and
a very natural definition, using
recursion - defining things in terms of
itself. So let's see how we can do that.
If you give the factorial function a
number n, it's going to make a choice
between doing one of two things. If the
number you give it is already 1, which is
the point where you're trying to count
down to, then there's nothing to do. So if
the number equals 1, then we just return
the result 1. Otherwise, what we're going
to do, is we'll take the number you're
given, and we'll multiply it by the
factorial of its predecessor. So for
example, if n was 3 we would take 3
times the factorial of 2. So this is a
recursive function because we're
defining factorial in terms of itself -
the factorial of any number n is defined
in terms of the factorial of n minus 1.
So you can see the way that this is
going to work - if you give it a number
like 3, it's going to loop round - two,
one, and so - on until it eventually
gets to one, and then it will stop and do
all the multiplies. So let's do a little
example of this running, to see that we
know how it actually works. If we take
factorial of 3 - so factorial of any
number that's not 1 is going to be that
number times the factorial
of its predecessor -
so we'll take 3 times the factorial of 2.
And then what do we do now? Well, we just
do the same thing again. We've worked out
what factorial of 3 is, now we need to
work out what factorial of 2 is, and
we just run the definition again,
recursively. So we copy down what we had
before. We have 3 times, and then we have
2 times factorial of 1. And then the
final step is the base case - this is
where the recursion stops - because
the factorial of 1, according to our
definition, was just 1. So we're going
to get 3 times 2 times 1, which is 6. So
that's a simple example of a recursive
function, and how it may run. So what
we were looking at in the last video was
the Lambda Calculus, which is a minimal
language for defining functions. And it's
only got three things in it - it's got
variables, like X, Y and Z; it's got a
way of building functions, that's the
lambda notation that we saw last day;
and it's got a way of applying functions,
that's just putting two things next to
each other. And everything else in the
Lambda Calculus is encoded in terms of
these three basic things. So an example
which we did last day was the logical
values True and False, and I'll just
refresh your memory about how we did
this last day. The two logical values are
True and False, and how do you represent
these, or encode these, in the Lambda
Calculus? You do it very simply as two
functions. So True is going to be encoded
as the function that takes two things, x
and y, and just gives you back the first
one, x. And then False is the opposite - it
takes two things, x and y, and it gives
you back the second one. And these
encodings can then be used to define any
other function which you'd like on the
logical values. Like, I think last day, we
looked at Not, and we looked at And, and
we looked at Or. So any other function
can be defined in terms of these two
encodings. And these encodings are very
natural - they express the
idea that, in programming,
True and False are often used to choose
between two different things. So if one
thing is True, you do something; and if
it's False, then you do something else.
And these two definitions just encode
this idea of choosing between one thing,
or another thing. What we're thinking
about today is recursion. And you can ask
yourself, if we have our definition like
the factorial function here, the key
thing in the definition is that it's
recursive - we're defining the factorial
function in terms of itself, recursively.
So how do we encode recursion in the
Lambda Calculus, which doesn't have any
sophisticated feature like that at all?
So let's start off by reducing the
problem a bit. Let me write down the very
simplest recursive definition which I
can think of. And the simplest possible
recursive definition is just a program
that loops - it doesn't do anything at all.
So here would be the program. So I just
say loop equals loop. And if you think
about running this thing, we say what's
the value of loop, or how do you execute
loop? Well, you just go to the right-hand
side, and you say, well it's loop. So you
go back to the left-hand side, and it's
just going to go around like this
forever - it's just going to kind of spin
on the spot, without doing anything at
all. So this is the simplest recursive
program which you could write down. So
how could I encode this behavior in the
Lambda Calculus? And the key to this is
something called self application - it's the
idea of applying something to itself - or
in this case, applying a function to
itself. So let me show you how to encode
loop. So the way this works is we will
define loop to be this function here. So
the first thing to observe is that we
have two functions in here, and in fact
two copies of the same function. If we look
at this function here, and this function
here, they're both exactly the same. So
what we're doing here is we're applying
this function to itself - it's the idea
of self application. And this actually
occurs at another level as well. If we
look at what each of these functions
actually does, it takes an input called x,
and then applies x to itself; so again,
this is the idea of self application -
we're taking something in here, and then
we're applying it to itself, and the
same is happening over here.
And it turns out that this idea of self
application is the key to how you do
looping, or recursion, in a
language which doesn't have support
for that feature. So let's actually
check that this thing actually has the
behavior that we'd like - check that it
actually performance looping. If we write
down the same thing again, we have lambda x,
x x, and then we have lambda x, x x. Let's
think about how we can actually run this
thing. So we need to remember what a
function actually does. So a function
takes an input, like x, and then it tells
you what to do with it - so in
this case it takes an x and just
makes two copies of it side by side. And
in this case, the x is this thing here -
this is the argument, or the input, to the
function - we're applying it to itself. So
what's going to happen is that this
input is going to be plugged in, or
substituted, for x and then we'll just
get two copies of the thing in the box.
So that's how you would run the function.
So if we write this down, we're going to
get two copies of the box, and inside the
box will be exactly the same thing. And
what you see here, is that in going from
here to here, we've got exactly back to
where we started. We started with this
expression here, which was the definition
of loop, and we've ended up with exactly
the same thing. And of course if we do
the same thing again, if we say this is a
function, this is its input, let's plug it
in, in the two places where we see x, then
we'll get exactly the same thing again.
So this thing is just going to go around
in circles. It will never get anywhere -
every time you run one step of it, it
will go back to exactly the same point,
so it encodes the idea of looping. So
that's a simple example. Let's have a
more general example of recursion. So
here's a little recursive definition. I'm
going to define a function called rec,
for recursion, and it's going to take
another function as an input, and what
it's going to do is apply that function
to rec of f. So what does this definition
actually do? Well, first of all, we can see
that it's recursive, because rec of f is
defined in terms of rec of f. But it's
not just looping around all the time -
it's got a function f here, sitting in
the way. So if you think about unwinding
this definition, what you'll get is f of f of
f of f, forever. If you run this recursive
program, it's just going to apply the
function f infinitely often. And this
turns out to be the idea of what's
called general recursion in Computer Science -
this is the most general pattern of
recursion you can have, and any other
recursive function can be encoded in
terms of this one. So if we can encode
rec in the Lambda Calculus, we can encode
any recursive function. But let me set
you a couple of exercises at this point.
Using the definition of rec, which is
recursive, how do you program loop? Define,
or redefine, loop to be rec of some
function. So you've got to figure out
what function to apply rec to here. It's
actually a very, very simple function -
it's probably the simplest, or it is the
simplest function, you could write down
in the Lambda Calculus, so don't try and
over complicate it - write down the
simplest function you can here, work
through the definition of rec, and you'll
see that it actually has the looping
behaviour. A slightly more interesting
exercise, and a bit more challenging, is
how to define the factorial function using
rec? And I'll give you a bit of a hint on
this one - what you need to do is pass it
lambda f, lambda n, and then you need to
figure out what you write for the
question mark here, okay. And what you'll
find, is that the function that you write
in here is not recursive - it's the non-
recursive part of the factorial function.
Okay, so that's a bit of a challenging
exercise. This one's quite easy,
this one's a little bit more challenging,
but you'll learn a lot about the way
recursion works in the Lambda Calculus
if you do these two exercises. So what
we've reached now is the point where,
if we can encode rec, which is general
recursion - any other recursive function
can be encoded in terms of that, or
defined in terms of that - if we
can encode rec, then we're done,
because that lets us do everything. So
it's a bit of a mouthful, so I haven't
tried to memorise it - I've just got
a copy pre-prepared here. Here is the
definition, or one possible definition,
of rec in the Lambda Calculus. And this is
what's known as the Y combinator. And if
you look at this, I mean it looks like a
jumble of symbols, but it's actually very
similar to loop. If we look back to see
the definition of loop, it had the idea
of self application, so we applied a
function to itself. And the function we
applied was lambda x, x x. And we saw, how
when you run that, it will actually
achieve the looping behaviour. If you look
at the definition of the Y combinator,
which is defined here, it's got exactly
the same structure. Here we have a function,
and here we have another copy of the
same function, so it's exactly the same
idea of self application. The only
difference here, we haven't got lambda x,
x x, we've got an f in the way, and that's
the f which we're going to be kind of
repeatedly applying when we do the
recursion. So this is the Y combinator.
It's not recursive, but it encodes
recursion. And this is a very simple but
powerful idea, and you can do this in
most programming languages, unless you
have some kind of type system which
would stop you from doing this. This
gives you a way of doing recursion in a
language which doesn't have any
recursion at all. If you want to know
where it comes from, it was invented by
a mathematician from the United States -
Haskell Curry, and this is the Haskell
who gives his name to the Haskell
programming language. So if anyone asks
you about the Y combinator, this is what
it is. If you want to know a bit more
about the Y combinator, you can of
course look online, and there's a very
nice Wikipedia page about this, where you
can find more details about these kind
of things, and see how to do some of the
calculations and proofs of some of the
things which I have been saying. But
actually, it's interesting that the top
hit on Google for Y combinator is not
this stuff. It's actually a company which
is called Y combinator. And you think, well
why would anyone call their company Y
combinator? If you look at the company's
web page, they've got a frequently asked
questions list, and one of the questions
is - why did you choose the name Y
combinator for your company? And they say
a number of things here - so Y combinator
is one of the coolest ideas in Computer
Science, and of course I'm going to agree
with this, and I think this is a very nice,
very interesting, fundamental idea
about how you do recursion in a language
which doesn't have recursion. And it's
also a metaphor for what this company
does. So the Y combinator is a
way of having programs that run
other programs, and in this case it's a
way of doing recursion in a language
which doesn't have recursion. And that's
basically what their company is doing -
they're a company that helps start
companies - they're a startup incubator in
Silicon Valley, and it's the same kind
of self application idea. They want
to help someone to make a company,
and it's the same thing here - we
want to have programs that run other
programs. So for me, this is certainly one
of the coolest ideas in Computer Science.
This is Alonzo Church, who was a mathematician
at Princeton University in the United
States, and he was the person who
invented the Lambda Calculus, and what he
was interested in, is what
is the notion of a function...